so we are doing developer commentary of
episode 5 it's hard to believe but after
20 years
Alan Blum and Richard level or gray have
come back to build all new content for
Duke Nukem 3d using a lot in pretty much
the original tools now the engine is
upgraded this developer and commentary
will talk about some of that you can
also tell that we're able to put a lot
more detail in these maps because of
increased performance of computer
hardware since the last 20 years it's
pretty exciting we're getting an all-new
episode for Duke Nukem 3d in the classic
style look at those high-tech fire
sprites
look at those high-tech fire sprites the
pyromania CD i think was that was like
the butter of sex artists back then
versus it was this library of all these
fire effects called the pyromania and it
was so good you can just buy the discs
and you have a license to use all those
effects yeah I still get a kick when I
see a movie
using an effect on fancy
if you turn to the right go down there's
a fire hydrant this is one of my
favorite things about duke3d is watch
this and if you as damage right now you
can walk up and you know sit and drink
from it and you would get one health
point for each drink like the fact that
just any interactivity at all is a
miracle this is I think your intended
critical path for users that didn't find
the secret of the rocket launcher
because you can open those doors and go
in the back door yeah
besides playing through it and try to
get to the exit back they were doing
everything they also calculated how long
it took you to get to that exit
yep so you know the fastest exit you can
actually run right around the back horn
right now I saw a video of one person
way back when and they would run up here
grab those steroids and use that to jump
out of this window across over to that
ledge and then around the corner while
on steroids jump it up in hitting the
exit when they're done and their first
ten seconds yeah the whole level is like
seven seconds or something insane
yeah look at look out the window what's
on the what's on the screen you can open
the theater window Oh what it's that
kind of theater I think every I think it
doesn't matter how old the people were
working on this game they all had the
mind of an adolescent
first Pig cop gets it it's almost
relevant again now we have so many cops
shooting people interesting like we only
with their people do you with your
period where this joke became less funny
and now I think we're back where
everybody just wants to hit the cop well
you know I don't hate the cops I respect
you